hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
soyou've 100% completed the
single-player campaign of Red Dead
Redemption to know neither have I
there's too much to do well read that
online is fast approaching and although
we don't have all the facts yet we do
know quite a few things about the online
portion of our cowboy adventure
he has 25 things you should know about
Red Dead online above all else the most
important point about online there's a
story and narrative to follow with
branching paths and subplots we all know
the story of the Wild West is the
highlight of the single-player portion
of the game and that law will continue
into online allowing us to play a
personal part in that story as you'd
expect NPCs will give us missions just
like in GTA online but story arcs will
be prevalent the interactions have been
described as cause-and-effect for
example a mission setup could include
stealing snake bites anti-venom
something quite small but once in
possession crossing snake infested areas
becomes less daunting cause-and-effect
to go alongside the story elements
online we will be our own unique
character this Wild West story will be
personalized we can choose our facial
features our stances and of course our
dress sense it's uncertain about our
facial hair and if it will grow in the
open world just like a single player but
we can visit the barbers to rectify that
at any point as we all know there are
two types of people in this world men
with beards and women which one of you I
want super quick point here emotes have
been confirmed
let's hope they introduced the dab that
was a thing in the 1800's wasn't it
microtransactions have been confirmed to
remember those shot cards in GTA online
yeah course you do whether you hated
them or absolutely hated them they are
likely to make a return in Red Dead
online my guess would be Buffalo cards
Rockstar have looked into other ways to
catch a whale and looked into
fortnight's way to monetize sadly
selling cosmetic items won't really work
in Red Dead online well at least not to
the same extent GTA and Red Dead are all
about the divide between the haves and
have nots whether that's through hard
work and perseverance are through buying
your way to the top microtransactions
are here to stay there's no doubt there
will be a huge revenue stream for
rockstar whether they allow it to break
the game we'll have to wait and see
another memory of GTA online you may
have are the server issues remember
being stuck in the clouds loading and
searching for Lobby space sometimes
you'd be straight back into the world
other times you'd be forced to wait and
wait and wait you get the idea
once the beta period is complete these
issues should be a thing of the past as
Rockstar hasn't scrimped on server
technology and have teamed up with a
highly reputable company to maximize
server responsiveness I'm talking about
GTA online quite a lot because that's
the basis of the world Red Dead online
draws from every little thing rockstar
has learned from that game has been
improved and updated before becoming
part of Red Dead a huge point many
players are wary of is the grind when
GTA 5 went online it was a revelation
but the grind to make money was always
present unless you bought those bloody
shot cards of course Rockstar seemingly
took this to the next level during the
last 12 months of GTA online with the
level of grind needed to compete with
real money players breaking the game
from any casual players personally I
stopped playing GTA online for two
reasons the biggest was the
disadvantages of refusing to put real
money into the game and the other was
the lack of heists Oh segue without a
doubt heists are coming to Red Dead
online I've asked as many people as I
know about their favorite moments in GTA
online and almost all agree the heists
are the crown jewel of online play in
Red Dead online these will continue in
all the ways you'd expect train heists
bank robberies jail breaks it's
uncertain how many heists we can access
at launch but one thing from GTA online
is certain every time a new heist was
added the user base doubled and players
returned to experience those bank jobs
and heists with their friends so how
would they work just like in the
single-player portion we need to
complete set up missions to be ready for
the main quest for example we'd need to
steal a shipment of high explosives and
connect them to support beams to take
down a train or maybe we'd need an air
balloon to keep an eye on our targets
who most likely won't ever look up
flight wasn't the human capability back
so no one checks above them speaking of
the air balloon one of the only
drawbacks to Red Dead Redemption too is
the numerous hours spent riding to each
location
I personally wrote for over 20 hours
during my playthrough of the
single-player campaign Rockstar have
said they are looking into quicker ways
to move around the map online although
we don't have any confirmation yet I'm
expecting that hot-air balloon to be a
quick way to get from say st. Denis to
Blackwater the air balloon mechanic is
only present in the main game during a
single mission and that is underutilized
to say the least another way to traverse
the map is that done in a little game
called fallout 76 they have a very
similar issue as their world doesn't
have high-speed cars or air travel
instead fallout uses the map to click on
a teammate or gang member and instantly
travel to their location that would
likely be too easy to use to grief other
players in Red Dead online so I'd expect
four or five markers around the world
which can be traveled too quickly
likely our camp our hideout there'll be
a few single-player crossover elements
in Red Dead online Rockstar have
confirmed all wildlife will remain in
the online experience hunting missions
have also been confirmed allowing us to
track down mythical beasts with our
friends similarly with fishing you know
because look how exhilarating that is
each to their own I suppose hmm crafting
has been confirmed in Red Dead online
should our gang need medicines or other
pre heist buffs we can craft them using
recipes and items found around the world
such as herbs which have just found out
is pronounced herbs in the US that
sounds so much cooler than herbs herbs I
love it I love it as in the
single-player mode horses have different
stats and other benefits but that won't
be our only way to move around the open
world we can ride with our gang on a
simple wagon or upgrade it to a chariot
for improved horse power wagons with
Gatling guns attached are confirmed too
but there'll be a bit pricey boat the
aforementioned air balloons and flying
machines found broken around the world
could also be other ways to move around
the world a few Rockstar devs have
suggested we may be responsible for
those flying machines working in the
1900s I've already said too much
move on we are going to need somewhere
to keep these fine vehicles how about a
three-story garage okay so that wasn't
really a thing back then but we are able
to buy properties around the game world
which will act as a home base or a gang
hideout picking the right location will
also net us a stable or a bond to hide
our wagons and home our horses speaking
of horses brand new species of horses
will be added to the online game and
these will only be accessible online if
you don't know your hungarian half-blood
from your Cantonese warmblood now's the
time to research thanks google I made
one of those up by the way here's a very
important point a few weeks ago I made a
joke that eventually a flying unicorn
that poops rainbows will be added to
read that online well I actually got a
response in short the time period of
1899 will not be broken by events or
items meaning my unicorn won't ever make
it into Red Dead online am I upset
hell no this is bloody great look at
what GTA online became Back to the
Future flying cars jetpacks men in
assless chaps I digress the point is the
time period is king it may borrow from
1020 years in the future but nothing
more except maybe aliens and time travel
once again I've said too much move on
the term used to describe Red Dead
online is roleplay and harmony again
using GTA online as the benchmark that
could not be further from the truth
as many of us had our experience ruined
by griefers and those people who derive
enjoyment from ruining the experience of
others Rockstar have noticed the toxic
members of the community and are
actively trying to rectify that in Red
Dead online they've even suggested that
those types of players will return to
GTA online soon after I'll keep my
fingers crossed on that one Red Dead
Redemption 2 uses a snap to target
aiming system which eliminates kill with
weaponry
long story short a three year old could
headshot you it's that easy to play so
stopping griefing is quite difficult
because there's no skill involved but
how can it be stopped
well it's quite simple actually
punishment of said griefers Red Dead
online brings across the witness system
and The Wanted levels from the solo
campaign if you're seen killing another
player unlawfully expect the Popol to
track you down the sheriff and the
Pinkertons will be on to you soon enough
if we are continuously being hunted by a
griefer we have the option to tell the
Lord
who will double their efforts to track
down that player placing a nice bounty
on their heads for any other player to
collect the red dead town isn't big
enough for the both of us griefers pack
your bags and get back to GTA online
anyone here a fan of Red Dead Revolver
back in the first iteration of Red Dead
online it was possible to see characters
from that game added to online this was
done through DLC through the legends and
killers pack this brought favorites Jack
Swift Buffalo Soldier and even Nate
Harlow into online could this happen
again in the updated version of Red Dead
online we shall wait and see going back
to the story for a moment it has been
confirmed our first mission online is
none other than a jailbreak we've
already seen a few of those in the
single-player campaign this will set up
the outlaw mentality instantly but how
will you play it out lore until the end
our lovable rogue tough choice Red Dead
online will begin with 50 levels of
progression to unlock it's unclear if
that will be the end of it or if the
number will continue like in GTA online
like in previous games each rank unlocks
a new item whether that's something
aesthetic like a hat maybe our satchel
capacity can be increased or even a
legendary weapon or two if there have to
be a grind there has to be a reward as
you'd expect a bucket load of game mode
will be added to Red Dead over time your
nemesis will be tracked races will be
available team deathmatch returns all
the usual you'd expect with a noticeable
addition Battle Royale I know it was
technically in the original Red Dead
online through the king of the hill mode
but as battle royale has taken over the
world it's only right that the Cowboys
lay down their claim as the game has
that snap to aiming mechanic this won't
be as tryhard as Call of Duty's blackout
or even fought Knights battle royale
this should be more about fun than skill
at launch later this month servers will
support 32 players but expect that
number to increase throughout 2019 a
smooth beta launch is the only thing
Rockstar are missing from their
impressive resume once the beta period
concludes and due to the sheer size of
the map more players will be added it's
almost certain
speaking of players when you and your
gang mates team up you'll create a posse
you can pit your Posse against other
gangs in the game world whether that's
AI controlled or straight-up warfare
with other real-life human beings but
who will be the boss of your gang of
Outlaws so as you feel up to the task do
are included online so yeah if you want
to change the pecking order in your
posse jewel for it want to see who has
to buy the new wagon for a heist duel
for it who has the best beard jewel for
you get the idea
Red Dead online will include events and
limited time modes at different points
around the year I doubt we'll get
snowfall Christmas day well this year at
least
but Halloween inspired zombie apocalypse
will likely arrive next year and other
events at regular intervals everything
is designed to keep us coming back to
the Wild West for years to come so there
we have it 25 things you should know
about Red Dead online everything begins
late November 2018 and will likely run
for years to come I don't know why I'm
still talking now because no one stays
until the end so I'm literally talking
to myself
yay anyone still here hello anyone if
you're here right till the end in the
comments I'll do my best to comment back
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been a bloody pleasure I'll see you
online
you